hey what's going on in spilled Barone
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
from Monday September 17th 2018 how's it
going how are you what's up with you um
how was your football Sunday I know
what's going on with me like I felt like
I had a cold now I don't know what I
have and my wife's like well maybe you
have allergies it's like I don't have
allergies I've never had allergies in my
life and she's just like well sometimes
there's there's late onset allergies so
she's got me thinking I have allergies I
never you know I thought allergies for
like people who had like inferior DNA
you know just like weak people you know
like the kind of puppy that the mother
ignores and just lets die doesn't want
to let it get any milk you know but
we're human beings and everybody's
special so you keep these people going
and then they just walk around constant
state of like you know isn't listening
to their nasally voices oh my god did
somebody eat lobster in the last month
and then you gotta like [ __ ]
vaccinate your house whatever it is de
fumer gate your house because somebody
with allergies comes by you know but
evidently I'm one of those people
you know my mom should have ignored me
who knew who know I maybe I have late
onset who dafuq it's allergies at 50 you
know it's funny about all you other
non-medical people out there right now
what are you doing you listen this
podcast and now you're googling this
[ __ ]
alright everybody's just addicted um I'm
gonna get the answer right now you know
do you ever ever consider the source not
to mention the the [ __ ] guy who's you
know looking for the information being
you not having a [ __ ] medical degree
all of a sudden you're like some doctor
I do it all the time that's why I got a
nutritionist cuz I was trying to learn
about food I just couldn't figure it out
everybody just you know at a conflicting
opinion it was like these goddamn
feminists and the guys with the
date-rape drug they just can't seem to
get on the same page no it's like
Democrats Republicans you know I mean
they all agree on what the problems are
they just sitting there pointing fingers
at each other these [ __ ] people in in
the food industry it's the same thing
you know I got the [ __ ] Giants
cowboys game on and there's some [ __ ]
[ __ ] he literally is sitting on the
field at a little to top table how much
of those tickets these guys are running
around [ __ ] smashing their brains out
right and then that's an incomplete pass
and then the guy puts his hands up like
where's the flag
sitting there like [ __ ] Julius what
is he see a high-ranking official at
that the Home Depot corporate office you
imagine like the jobs that we have
nowadays can you [ __ ] imagine if you
just met people from the past and
they're just looking at you do what what
do you do and we'd all be saying this
[ __ ] and just be like they would all be
just looking at you don't do anything
and your wife does what she what like
the whole [ __ ] nothing would make
sense you know I wonder if it's gonna be
like that in a hundred years like we can
actually you know if we were still
around
a couple hundred years we could just
[ __ ] look down on people and what
their jobs are because robots are now
[ __ ] I don't know entering data I
don't know people I don't pretend to
understand but how did you guys in
travel was your second week of football
mine was you know really we lost it
wasn't that big a deal though
everyone's gonna make a big deal you
know Edelman's not back yet it's the
second week of the [ __ ] season you
know you know what do you know what what
the [ __ ] okay go [ __ ] Jacksonville
they're all gonna be [ __ ] freaking oh
my god we finally beat the Patriots does
this mean we win the Superbowl alright
that's what everybody does everybody
gets all [ __ ] excited like you know
when you watch an action movie you know
the Rambo guy is he freaking out now the
Chuck Norris freakout now you know
freaks out the
I was gonna [ __ ] die dad sooo so
everybody relax
you know Jets fans how many times are
you gonna get you're gonna let the lazy
New York sports media [ __ ] gas up
another guy alright he said to [ __ ]
solid weeks he's gone one and one he's
thrown for 300 yards whatever [ __ ]
both weeks very impressive you know but
you don't become a legend in September I
know you're hopeful I mean even the
firemen came back when did he come back
you guys were such [ __ ] you know what
the [ __ ] is wrong the Jets fans steed
they chased a fireman how long are you
cursed for post 9/11 in New York you
chased a fireman out of your own [ __ ]
stadium and you got the balls to think
that a couple of decent weeks of
football then all of a sudden you're
walking down the street talking to the
camera talked calling out Tom Brady Tom
Brady the man you guys all we all wanted
to be Tom Brady we all wanted to be
good-looking be the quarterback marry a
supermodel have a nice [ __ ] dimple in
our chin full head of [ __ ] hair Mary
I already said that part right [ __ ]
away win five [ __ ] Super Bowls get a
respectful [ __ ] nod from joe Montana's
you're putting on your yellow [ __ ]
jacket right we all wanted that all
right well guess what despite all these
[ __ ] Instagram accounts out there
that are telling you you can do anything
you want everybody's [ __ ] special
reality is there's only one Tom Brady
all right so all you green [ __ ] down
there I'm happy for you I'm happy that
you're excited but you might want to
reel it in a little bit you know you
ever have a friend of yours every time
he's [ __ ] me to check he thinks
that's the one you know and you just go
like I'm not to pick this guy up off the
[ __ ] mad again how many times can I
sit across from you she cried and you
can beer alright what are you just gonna
[ __ ] abroad and move on that's the
problem these Jets fans they [ __ ]
romantics oh they fell is Eli I know
throw up for a touchdown with a min and
a half left - a little too late you know
they probably let him go right down the
field I love listening to people flip
out this time of year you know I'm
actually okay I'm taping this Sunday
night all right I'm gonna predict I'm
just gonna go around the league look at
the scores here I'm gonna predict the
[ __ ] overhyping me with my [ __ ] 50
year old allergies I have allergies you
I can't there's no fight oh I won't
allow it
very of a varicose vein I can't I can't
[ __ ] compound that with an allergy
anyways when I had it right here I had
the NFL scores didn't I isn't that what
happened now why wouldn't you go for two
there then you're only down by nine
that's just three three drives with
three field goals you could get back in
this game with the minute 28 left I mean
he's gonna have you gonna have some
[ __ ] questions you answer after this
game by people who never got picked in
gym class all right let's go around the
league here we go the scores here all
right this is what my predictions are
gonna be all right the Chiefs
I mean I'll tell you right now I see a
lot of people cobble a dually but this
Patrick my home base however you say is
the homes I mean just got if he keeps
this up
can't you see me we'll be undefeated and
they will win your first Super Bowl
since Super Bowl four and Patrick
cojones is going to have the greatest
season ever in the history of the NFL I
do have to tell you though if Patrick
Mahoney's went mahomes was [ __ ] doing
this [ __ ] for the Jets or anywhere in
New York good lord they would have
declared a [ __ ] state of emergency
onside kick the Giants get the ball look
at this here we go
there's still not enough [ __ ] time
left but this is when you as a gamblin
man you like this flipping out although
I think the Giants were favored am I
wrong I have no idea they're gonna
[ __ ] sit there and freak the [ __ ] out
Ryan Fitzpatrick I beat the bucket is
jesus [ __ ] christ a to know the first
time since [ __ ] 2014 it's just gonna
be their year I don't know [ __ ] about
anything at this point all I could say
about the Buccaneers is there too and oh
they've scored 75 points and they've led
up 61 all right
40 of those [ __ ] points whether the
goddamn Saints so you know I don't know
you know you know you know [ __ ] win
games forty eight forty and [ __ ] like
that in the in the playoffs so I would
be relaxed with them you know who
obviously the most impressive team in
the league has got to be the [ __ ]
ramps this scored 67 points that only
led up 13 I know they played the [ __ ]
Raiders they bucket diggity but they did
what they were supposed to do they beat
the [ __ ] out of them after a lackluster
first buck and a half
Jaguars looked good though but anytime
you got Tom Coughlin anywhere near it
you're gonna win they look good Patriots
you know who knows I don't know but I
mean we'll see we'll see what happens
with Edelman comes back we had a couple
of [ __ ] injuries I don't believe in
the Dolphins even though they're two and
oh I feel bad for the bills
the Chiefs God knows that she's the
Chiefs love nothing more than [ __ ]
[ __ ] stroking their fans in September
well their fans finally get to bust and
not come playoff time or they once again
go home with [ __ ] blue balls
who else but I think that's [ __ ] in
Moseley the old Packers I like the
Packers I like the Rams and then I like
the direction the jaguars are going in
and the Chiefs I just too many [ __ ]
times
they did it last year everybody gets all
[ __ ] excited and then buh-buh-buh-buh
mob sudden the holidays come along and
right then they all start dressing up
like [ __ ] Native Americans you know
they eat too much pumpkin bread and then
they just [ __ ] the bed and [ __ ]
November I have no idea basically I'm
judging the entire franchise at what
they've done in the past even though
they probably have brand new personnel I
still believe I still believe in Jon
Gruden despite all these people that I
know they were winning all day today and
then they lost in the end but this is a
[ __ ] franchise that has been [ __ ]
lost at sea for a long time I've been
impressed with you know Jon Gruden
played a great his team played a great
first half against the best team in the
league I think the [ __ ] Rams the most
impressive team so far and you know play
damn good against the Broncos not good
enough long enough or whatever I still
believe in this guy so then so there's
my two cents there's my [ __ ] white
noise no pun intended they Eli goes DP
incomplete you know what they said when
I was watching the Patriots game
what's-his-face there Tony Romo another
[ __ ] gem another gem like he's just
like everything second I quote the
psycho to flying every time you fly you
learn something right every time you
listen to a game at Tony Romo is is
doing the color you [ __ ] learn
something there was a guy in the Jaguars
he had our guy beat and he was running
along that was a you know run along the
sideline whatever we call that [ __ ]
pattern and he was right on the sideline
and Tony said if he ran two yards more
in like more towards the field it's such
an easier throw for the quarterback he
said he actually ran the route wrong and
I don't know if he got forced outside
but just you know Tony's also gonna stop
beside with the [ __ ] quarterback but
it was so [ __ ] interesting going oh
yeah because then he could maybe throw
to the outside of
shoulder that guy still has a step or a
step and a half to adjust to the ball if
you just run right on the sideline the
[ __ ] guys like a half step behind you
now he has to throw a goddamn strike
what does he Eli Manning and the [ __ ]
last drive of a Super Bowl alright
enough of that [ __ ] talk it's still
really early I called them my bookie
people
I picked the Jaguars I talked to Paul
virzi I picked the Lions his lock of the
week was San Francisco and I was like I
don't think I don't think the [ __ ]
Lions are as bad as that first game
that's the thing when you [ __ ] the bed
the first [ __ ] week cuz you gotta
have a game where you just suck what are
you 16 games he's gonna come out flight
you're just gonna [ __ ] suck right but
when it happens the first week of the
year everybody looks like it's just what
they're gonna do all year right yeah but
we get you made your point
all right whatever I picked the Giants
I'm gonna lose this one and I had one
other one I think I went to and one I
went to and one the first week with my
bookie and I think I went to win one
this week I call him in every week I
called the sports gambling podcast and I
give you my picks and my lock of the
week was that somebody was gonna get
fired for criticizing the woman that did
the play-by-play and I was [ __ ] wrong
I thought someone was gonna do someone
was gonna [ __ ] jump on that fish hook
and then that was going to be it anyways
congratulations to Frank Gore passing
Curtis Martin very quietly the guy is
fourth all-time I don't know if you get
to see too many more of these guys the
way they [ __ ] throw handoffs now the
only people in front of him now is
Walter Payton Barry Sanders and Emmitt
Smith and I don't think anybody's ever
going to catch em it the way the game
has changed and that's it there you go
there's my there's my [ __ ] take on
the whole [ __ ] thing for this week
all right how long how long did that
burn up 15 and a half minutes of your
life that you're never going to get back
all right this weekend I am scheduled to
be out in Virginia I think those gigs
will be good and then I'm in South
Carolina I haven't been keeping up too
much on the hurricane I just keep seeing
ya hate see you know who the [ __ ] wants
to watch people losing their houses I
don't get why do I want to watch that
well sitting at Hurricane Florence the
hurricane Fitzpatrick hurricane Florence
hurricane flo-jo hurricane Florence
Florence wreaks havoc in North and South
Carolina
all right so Virginia is okay so I got
two gigs there now this is the hardest
thing after a hurricane happens is who
do you give you money to do you know to
me how do I make sure the money that I'm
gonna donate gets to the right [ __ ]
gets to that person obscene on TV by the
way you see helps people get rescued all
those old people people in wheelchairs
[ __ ] broke-ass people that's what I
was talking about people we're gonna get
the [ __ ] over there a lot of them can't
a lot of them can oh man look at that
jesus [ __ ] christ do you see that
thing that rogen [ __ ] posted on
instagram who that guy was he was doing
this weird thing was he's trying to act
like he was leaning into the wind and it
just didn't look real and then two
people walked by in the background like
totally normal I love what that [ __ ]
happens the best one ever is what the
guy was in the boat and then people just
walked by and then what are you gonna do
it at that point is he gonna get out of
the boat
I like the cameraman to how he zoomed in
a little guy he tried to do him a solid
must be his drinking buddy or something
like that
so anyways alright well hurricane
Florence hopefully the waters will
recede I don't know man I don't want I
don't know I I got check with my agent
to see if the South Carolina would still
going on Jesus Christ I wonder if those
[ __ ] bankers that made off all that
[ __ ] money off of those people then
you watch them lose their
if there's even a day you know there's
not an ounce of [ __ ] guilt do you
yeah you did and if they don't give a
[ __ ] they don't give a [ __ ] here we are
going after [ __ ] Isis where these fat
[ __ ] [ __ ] who [ __ ] everybody their
own countrymen at least Isis has the
decency to go after people and that
there aren't their own country but these
[ __ ] bankers that goddamn committed
treason I don't know much about the
world but I believe if you did what they
did here in Southeast Asia you get put
to death one of those [ __ ] countries
then what the [ __ ] is the coach of the
Giants did they get rid of that [ __ ]
fat guy that guy who looked like they
just took him out of the [ __ ]
mezzanine level wait a second don't they
get rid of that guy Giants head coach
alright let's see who he is why does it
always go to Wikipedia now alright wait
a second Tom Coughlin's they had Bob
McAdoo Ben McAdoo but they were like Ben
Mecca don't get the [ __ ] out of here
sorry then Steve spag a new low and he
was an interim coach now they got Pat
that shoe it looks like a winner even
though they're [ __ ] Owen - gotta love
an older guy that keeps himself in shape
you know now here he doesn't have
[ __ ] white hair I don't know he was I
don't know the [ __ ] guy was anyone's
those can I get on with the podcast here
I didn't do [ __ ] this week I'm such a
[ __ ] weird weekend I thought I was
gonna be on the road and then mother
nature came [ __ ] screaming in is
there gonna be another hurricane behind
this one remember that parade of [ __ ]
last year we had like [ __ ] 20 20
hurricanes in a row of spines feminists
didn't get upset by that you know to
constantly name the
by women's names insinuates that we
caused problems in men's lives I don't
know what they [ __ ] say though I
actually did a gig there did a a benefit
Thursday night the last time I was on
stage and you know I gotta be honest it
was one of these you know they had like
a red carpet knowledge [ __ ] and I was
just I saw some of the people I was at
I'll bet I'm gonna [ __ ] Bob on this
one it was the exact opposite
that's like one of the hardest I've ever
gone on stage and recent [ __ ] memory
as far as like [ __ ] I'm gonna say
this [ __ ] I'm gonna say that and it
went great everybody was flipping out
[ __ ] enjoying it laughing a bunch of
women came up to me meaning for saying
how funny they thought it was and I got
to be honest with you I think the same
way the mass media misread this last
election they are miss reading
we're like people's idea of what is
funny and what isn't because I was in
Hollywood people liberal ground [ __ ]
zero and all those jokes killed and
everybody thought it was funny and I was
sitting there you know I've to every
other [ __ ] you know is that the one
that's gonna get me in trouble
is this the [ __ ] gag if they get that
guy am I gonna have to [ __ ] you know
it's [ __ ] unbelievable now like you
can't even have like an opinion that's
what kills me it's not that you did
something if you just have an opinion
that does not agree with them then all
of a sudden you have to go on TV and you
have to [ __ ] apologize I don't I
don't this it's just it I really feel
that they're gonna make a movie about
this era and it's gonna be like the Red
Scare like McCarthyism meets like
[ __ ] MySpace or something who's gonna
be in it you know there's people just
sit around how many more innocent men
are we gonna let suffer
oh my god what is this guy wearing he's
wearing a [ __ ] sports bra I am
watching the Dallas Cowboys right now
and this guy just came out wearing a
[ __ ] a half shirt slash sports bra
from the [ __ ] 1980s did he steal that
from one of the cheerleaders it's not
even a half shirt he's it's a bra
he's covering his male pectoralis
there's still been weigh-in on Zack
Prescott right and then you know what's
gonna happen there's got to be a bunch
of people who like to wear male sports
bras that are gonna be offended and be
like why did you zoom in on his manly
beard when you could have shown this
other guy who's essentially dressed like
a spice girl oh my god god bless him I'd
love to be that [ __ ] ripped I don't
know if there was ever a point in my
life I could [ __ ] pull off what this
guy's pulling off holy [ __ ] [ __ ] oh
my god god bless him god bless him
anyways I really am an old I'm an old
man now Christ what are these kids wear
it you know I actually I should be in
full support of this cuz we wor have
shirts in the 80s I never had the nerve
to wear one outside of the house you
know I was just too pasty and I never
thought I had [ __ ] abs enough to do
it you know what I mean and I didn't you
know a few things I never thought would
come back half shirts and [ __ ] Larry
Bird short shorts and they they are back
with the [ __ ] vengeance it really is
does anybody look worse than a [ __ ]
football helmet than Eli Manning I mean
he's first ballot Hall of Fame
quarterback and first ballot Hall of
Fame like I don't know how much more
does that guy have to win before you you
like you could look at him wearing a
helmet there's just something about it
he looks like he's
sitting between two [ __ ] muscular
people on a plane he like he got the
middle seat this shoulders ambushing his
face together I got a lot of balls
considering the way I [ __ ] look huh
anyways anyways that [ __ ] ran out of
batteries you wouldn't know cuz i just
said anyways cuz it magically ended with
me saying anyways but I did yeah I just
did I just did like another ten minutes
of the podcast after I was talking about
Eli sitting between two muscular guys on
a [ __ ] plane and I don't know you
know I got to read these goddamn I got
to read the [ __ ] advertising again so
know this alright this is my second I've
already read these one time so I should
breeze through these I breeze through
these anyways my bookie yeah that
cricket there's a loud-ass [ __ ]
cricket with maybe that's the amount of
people leaving the podcast at this point
I have no idea my bookie
you know ever since I see this podcast
people have been asking for my advice
ask me you know ask me what team do I
bet on the truth is I don't know who's
gonna win that's the truest piece of
advertising that's ever been written for
me to say I don't know who's gonna win
but if you think you know you gotta
check out my bookie okay remember who
you're betting on is just as important
as who you betting with that's why this
[ __ ] cricket is gonna drive me crazy
that's why I always tell people to bet
with my bookie do i I guess I do
according to the copy trust me guys they
are your best bet this season they've
been in business for you have great
reviews online and their mobile site is
easy to use listen to that cricket it's
trying to get its [ __ ] bet in for the
Thursday afternoon Thursday night kick
my bookie you win they pay it's not like
these other [ __ ] bookies where you
win you pay listen if you win they pay
if you lose you have to pay don't ever
forget that
all right they have in game live betting
the most rewarding perks in the business
if you fantasy guys out there huh stop
robbing one out to you seventh grade
math teacher you can even bet on the
over-under on how many fantasy points a
player will score
each game it's the game within the game
it's like it's like the middle-earth of
football
my bookie is slammed with new batters it
wants to give everyone the best service
possible if you're willing to deposit
after 7:00 p.m. Eastern Time they'll
give you an additional $25 free to play
on deposits over $100 do you think
that's why they're doing it are they
adjusting the line I have no idea that's
[ __ ] amazing that they're doing it so
jump on it because who gives a [ __ ] all
right
either way you know it's a [ __ ] shot
one bad away from you join now and my
bookie will match your deposit dollar
for dollar
use promo code BIR to activate the offer
visit my bookie online today that's my
bookie and don't forget to use the promo
code bir when creating your account to
claim up to $1,000 in free play and now
and now if you're willing to hold out
until after 7:00 p.m. you can get an
extra 25 bucks for free by using the
promo code sorry
bir 25 it's up to you guys but I'd wait
until after dinner and take the extra
money you play you when you get paid and
listen to that after the part I can't
sue that one but the you listen after
Thursday podcast you can hear what I
call it a sports gambling podcast with
Sean green and rein Quinlan dollar shave
club I'm watching a sports show right
now both guys are wearing shoes and one
guys wearing high-top sneakers just to
let you know that he's into sports even
though he has on a suit at heart he's a
guy who goes he watches the sports he
must be the crazy guy in the show
alright Dollar Shave Club everybody no
matter what you do in the bathroom to
get ready Dollar Shave Club has
everything you need to look feel and
smell your best they have amazing shower
stuff hair styling products toothbrushes
and toothpaste and of course razors and
shape supplies just to let you know I
finally got those one wipe Charlies
problem they do work amazing but the let
you know there is some sort of like a
tingling afterwards alright almost like
they put a wintergreen lifesavers in
there or something I have no idea but
just let you know that that's you know
just in case you get you think you got a
[ __ ] tapeworm or something working
its way out of you you might shave your
whole body to get ready
for a bike race - all a shave clubs
executive razor and shave butter can
help you you might do your hair to get
ready for your soccer match
Boogie's by Dollar Shave Club and get
can help you style your hair right I've
already read this the thing is no matter
what you do to get ready Dollar Shave
Club is everything you need this is my
second I've already read this I already
had a rehearsal I'm still [ __ ] it up
right now you can get ready with an
amazing deal on any one of their status
debts like daily essentials essential
starter set but you can't go wrong with
any of them head over to
dollarshaveclub.com / / pick your own
Dollar Shave Club status set for just
five dollars after you started set
product ship at regular price and make
sure you check out their new video -
that's dollar shave club com / burn
Dollar Shave Club comb / / I'm hoping
with this record a cut out it didn't cut
out the [ __ ] I was talking about about
f1 in MotoGP so in case it did I might
[ __ ] DirecTV hasn't been working well
and I missed the last couple races but
I'm back in there
alright back in there alright stamps
calm everybody the US Postal Service is
a very important tool for any business
stamps or comb is the easiest way to
access all the amazing services of the
post office staff calm never closes
print postage for lettuce or packages at
your convenience 24/7 print postage for
any class mail for any class mail right
from your own computer buy and print
official US postage for any letter any
package any class of mail using your own
computer or printer they'll send you a
digital scale that automatically
calculates the exact postage stamps com
will even help ya decide the best place
of class of mail based on your needs no
need to leased an expensive postage
meter and there are no long term
commitments I use stamps all come to
send out my posters 50 for my tour
called 50 simply called 50 50 simply
read is now 50 include your personal
recommendation well I'm a [ __ ] if I can
figure out how to do it so can you
right now you too can enjoy the
stamps.com service without any special
offer that includes a four week trial
plus the postage in the digital scale
you know I love about having stamps talk
comma in my [ __ ] house is I got a kid
now alright by the time I
I put the kid to bed the post office is
closed so I can get everything all
[ __ ] ready to go I got a jump on the
day if I do that and I get all the
dishes done
oh I wake up in the greatest mood ever
go to stamps.com click on the microphone
at the top of the homepage and type in
bird that stamps comm enter burrow
alrighty then
I know I keep teasing you guys with this
[ __ ] Eastern European tour but it is
coming back together it is slowly but
surely it's coming together well we had
you know they haven't gone for like
[ __ ] 17 days and you know I can't do
that
I got a kid all right I'm gonna come
home the kids not gonna recognize me so
I'm gonna break it up into two tours
that is the game plan oh that's cool of
Bills quarterback retired at [ __ ] a
half-time I hope you wanted to do that
he made one last stop and he said I'm
out of here it's kind of a cool way to
do it anyways I will definitely be
getting out there and I know I people
from Australia but asking me I'm gonna
try to make something like next year I
think I might do like a couple of those
little runs there when I'm overseas and
maybe tape another special I don't know
I don't know we'll see alright
almond fama hey Bill thanks for the semi
shout-out to the blue moon ash alone
tree nut the almond on your podcast last
Monday oh yes it was the moon blue moon
of the nuts on September 10th 2018 I was
walking through my aural almond orchard
listening to your podcast when you
talked about seeing your first almond
tree I live in the region of Thunder
Valley wasn't able to make it to the
show but I hope that's not your last
time in Sacramento area I [ __ ] loved
that gig that gig was so much fun that
crowd was awesome I'll tell you right
now there's a lot of [ __ ] out there but
almond farmers they're alright you guys
are all right with me
anyways he says I am a tree nut farmer
in California is a prominent producer of
many tree nut crops including almonds
walnuts pecans and pistachios yes yes
and yes
standings
she's dead look they like the Doritos of
nuts what you want you start eating me
of your [ __ ] you got to get airlifted
out of there you're gonna eat the rest
of them almond bloom in February and
it's a beautiful time of the year if you
and your family are ever up here please
stop by for a visit
well I gotta be honest with you I
respect farmers even though I make fun
of you when I'm in farming country
because that's what I do
what am I gonna say I respect farmers
and get that douchey applause break you
know like I'm some politician running
for office
okay and now next I'm gonna say exactly
what you want to hear you know a lot
only my opponent so itself said that you
guys are you guys are lazy but I'll tell
ya there's gonna be a boom I've been
here for the last three days but I don't
think I've ever seen anybody we're gonna
do people every will lose their [ __ ]
mind with their dumb [ __ ] American
flag hat isn't it weird how dumb people
are that actually show up to [ __ ] like
that are you know I always noticed that
like when I was doing the Opie and
Anthony show they had a bunch of people
out listeners that were [ __ ] smart
but whenever you did a remote the
[ __ ] animals that showed up and it's
the same [ __ ] thing what politicians
go on the road you know they're running
for those primaries and stuff and you
just look at the people in the [ __ ]
crowd you know
then errantly they gotta be they they
don't have a [ __ ] job right what are
they doing there well maybe they're down
there because they need a job and they
believe in that candidate well yeah
folks just [ __ ] vote for them in the
meantime go go [ __ ] hit the bricks
and try to find a job Oh bill what are
you gonna stop oversimplifying things
and actually trying to read up on stuff
I don't know what a lot of the charm of
the podcast be gone if I did that you
know
is it me or is the sound of that cricket
[ __ ] deafening it's like it's in here
it's like it's slowly sneaking up on me
to [ __ ] you know is that the latest
oh my God look at that two young kids
playing guitar holy [ __ ]
did they play the national anthem oh
thank god there's hope there's hope so
they keep playing the Gibson Les Paul
you spoil God set up ephone let's go
save the [ __ ] a rich kid you know rich
kid goes to the concert it's like I like
that drug getting to the parents go on
buy the exact one you know does that kid
ever make it did you ever meet one rich
kid that made it can you say Donald
Trump made it you have to even though he
was rich he turned to millions into
billions and then he began he he's he's
[ __ ] president in the United States
no matter how much you hate the guy you
got a MIDI he made it he is a [ __ ]
American success story like if you were
at the track okay and you I mean what if
he was the odds what were the [ __ ]
odds I can't imagine I can't imagine I
still cannot [ __ ] believe that guy
pulled that [ __ ] off you know it's like
watching Tom Brady throw for 500 yards
in a Super Bowl and still somehow losing
like how does that happen
all right so I've been under the weather
the last couple of days but I stayed on
the I stayed on the diet and uh I'll
dude I have a [ __ ] I have a story but I
can't tell it right now I have to wait I
gotta wait of like months from now or I
feel like I can tell the [ __ ] story
but anyways I watched that boxing match
you know
that Triple C guy where I don't know any
I've been away from boxing for so
[ __ ] long I just got so fed up with
how [ __ ] corrupt it was and uh just
getting burnt on pay-per-views you don't
I mean like I really feel like Floyd
Mayweather the people that still won't
give it up how great that guy is like
it's just a [ __ ] shame that that guy
didn't fight Pacquiao in the 2000 you
know that we all got taken for a [ __ ]
ride when he did and now I'm seeing that
he's got to fight him again and I mean
personally I think that guy is
undeniably one of the greatest of all
time without a [ __ ] doubt I mean you
can't argue that but I really think
these these cash grabs that just doesn't
help me in but maybe he doesn't give a
[ __ ] you don't of me fighting column and
Gregor and I hit a fight like [ __ ]
Pacquiao again I don't know but anyways
but I watched that fight couple of
[ __ ] warriors I came in over to a
party and I saw like the last three
rounds of it I was like [ __ ] I wish I
saw this whole thing but I remember
virzi was giving me [ __ ] because they
like you know dude I can't get into
[ __ ] MMA I really love boxing boxing
like it's so much better and blah blah
blah blah blah and I have to admit a
great [ __ ] boxing match as far as
like combat sports
I still you know what I have to agree I
don't think he can touch it and you know
what I like about it because I love MMA
[ __ ] love the [ __ ] but like like when
you watch those like this stand-up game
in MMA you can't touch a boxer now I
know all you MMA guys gonna flip out
yeah you put a box or in his back and
he's done I understand it but it's the
fact that all they do is throw punches
like how [ __ ] good they are at boxing
it's incredible like the the level of
skill and those guys were just in the
center of the ring from the last three
rounds that I watched and essentially
just bangin just beating the [ __ ] out of
each other and I know a lot of people
didn't like the
the decision and I always go to how
corrupt [ __ ] boxing is and the thing
that I like about the UFC is despite the
fact that it's sort of like Apple or
it's like this borderline monopoly and
uh but they can at least you know the
best guys fight the best guys for the
most part I know it's not a perfect
system but there's not like you know
three different leagues and somebody has
to try to unify the title and all that
[ __ ] alright for some [ __ ] reason I
went to I just hit stop against and I
got three [ __ ] ones I gotta end it
together I'm such an idiot
anyways yeah so was that you know [ __ ]
I'll tell this story if I'm second uh
name any names I was at this party when
he's like really cool LA parties that
you hope you get invited to and I got
invited to it and they had Cupid cigars
there which was [ __ ] incredible is a
beautiful house just beautiful house and
I went into the I went into this room
with you know the TV room they had that
they had the boxing match on and I look
over and a [ __ ] one of the greatest
boxers for when I was growing up was
there and it was [ __ ] hilarious
because it was him and then just a bunch
of regular people like me who didn't
fight you know you know ever or whatever
you know so he's sitting there so it was
like you didn't want to comment you
didn't want to say anything but you
wanted to say something because you
wanted to show that you knew something
was [ __ ] hilarious people were trying
to be everybody was like you know
wanting to say something but then kind
of like not one of those [ __ ]
hilarious so I didn't say that like I
ain't saying [ __ ] [ __ ] there's no
[ __ ] way I'm gonna be like throw a
left hook his hands are too low why I
set it up with the jab like I'm gonna
[ __ ] say that with this champion
sitting there right so my interaction
was this at the end of the fight that
was the decision and this will the
greatest fighters of all time was just
he went ah man come on and I just said
no anyway now
and that was my interaction I left the
room as I got I got me interaction but
there was no [ __ ] way
there was no [ __ ] way I just you know
I just watched a fight and was praying
to God he would make some comments which
he did a couple of times it was just
like oh my god this is unbelievable
don't leave I let anybody have a [ __ ] on
[ __ ] la I'm telling you you get out
here you bust your [ __ ] ass and then
I'm telling you the [ __ ] people that
you meet even just for two seconds and
you have a one-word exchange it's like
you got to be kidding me
I remember a long time ago when I was I
was just struggling this business and I
was on the [ __ ] the Fox lot and I
just bombed some audition and I was just
like what am i doing out here I
shouldn't be out here I should be in New
York trying to get better as a comedian
that's just it I just knew this wasn't
my road so I was walking out and I was
all [ __ ] depressed and as I was
walking across the lot [ __ ] Henry
Winkler this was like 20 years ago right
around the time he was doing the water
boy just came walking by and I was like
that was [ __ ] that was Henry [ __ ]
Winkler I just got that that's how
[ __ ] cool is that I am somehow was in
his [ __ ] life for like five seconds
whatever I'm doing leads to meeting that
guy and then like [ __ ] I don't know
20 years after that Bill hader's show
Barry comes out and next thing you know
they want me to interview the cast and
UPS [ __ ] sitting there talking to
Henry with them it's an incredible place
that probably won't be here look this
global warming I don't know who knows
I'd say get out of here now while you
still can't you know go down to Miami
check these places these places are
gonna be like somebody like you know
when you're old at talking about how you
you yeah
Pompey III was there man [ __ ] yeah I was
there before the waters came up I was
[ __ ] there I did so blow I got my dick
sucked and I had some [ __ ] crab legs
except you can say like an old man yeah
I get to watch to sea Krait whatever the
[ __ ] you say that like doing blow at
that point what probably beats like you
know bringing up doing the Watusi
whatever the [ __ ] that was what was it
like some sort of minor dance you know
like what qualified is a [ __ ] date
like it isn't amazing just how human
beings progressed creatively there like
the Charleston Charleston Charleston but
up but a boom boom right and now like
what what how well some of these kids
can [ __ ] dance just in clubs it's
like back in the day like Fred Astaire
would be asking for a goddamn lesson
it's like Odell Beckham ever since he
made that falling backwards while
getting interfere with one-handed like
as far back as you can reach behind your
head catch nobody ever made it catches
like that now like I don't know what
they're doing that doing this thing with
their strength and then their fingers or
they're just practicing it like the guy
in the Jaguars did it like I watched
that the only thing it was as oh I can't
say it was as good as Odell cos if that
was the first guy to do it an E and the
big thing was he was getting interfere
dwith while falling down backwards this
guy just he just reached out like it was
like spider-man just snag the thing they
moved it around so the defender couldn't
knock it out of his hand and like that's
like that's sort of the joy I got him in
it's like the Jordan effect like that
[ __ ] that you know Kobe was doing like
biting like they all saw Jordan do it
and then they added it to their game
because he showed they hate you
this is possible what are you talking
about I don't know
I'm trying to say something positive
before I try and try to say how great la
is and then the back of my head I'm like
you know it's gonna be [ __ ] I don't
know what it's gonna be all I know is I
got a weird feeling that it's gonna be
all green and it's gonna be raining like
the [ __ ] rainforest you know they
said it's gonna be like you gets gonna
be like weird weather I think it's gonna
be just everything like whatever it used
to be like the East Coast is gonna get
all [ __ ] hot it's gonna be a goddamn
desert and then Audi is gonna be like
lush lie don't think of any lush lid
that's just wishful [ __ ] thinking I
don't know who the [ __ ] knows who the
[ __ ] they've always been saying that
we're gonna fall into the goddamn ocean
and all that [ __ ] you guys watch any of
that college football what a [ __ ]
weekend you know what when I went out to
go to that party I could feel that Ohio
State TCU game was good was I knew I was
leaving early and I'd so far I think I
missed the game of the year so far
and by the way Oh before I get move on
to the next game TCU by the way how
quickly are they on their way to
probation you know I don't get these
guys these guys came out of nowhere they
were great and then they fell off what
you see now all of a sudden they're
great again
I'm telling at Texas and it's three
letters TCU SMU I'm telling you there's
something there I'm just [ __ ] with
you TCU is what I think I can love
watching that team and the exciting his
health and almost had a great comeback
against Ohio State and their two and oh
well their coach is suspended he's
allowed to coach during the [ __ ] week
but on Saturdays he is not allowed to
coach tell me I don't have some sort of
headset wire thing going on or some [ __ ]
Urban Meyer
anyways plowing ahead here that kid from
North Texas who did the the fake fair
catch the next time he calls for a fair
catch he better be waving a goddamn
white flag there's that dude is gonna
get stuck for the rest of the [ __ ]
year because he he humiliated whoever
the [ __ ] he did that too when people see
[ __ ] like that you lay a [ __ ]
that to me then they give you the old
right there Fred
so keep your head on a swivel there
Sonny I still don't understand how the
[ __ ] he pulled that off
you know big time confidence
big time [ __ ] confidence did I read
from the almond farmer yet that I did I
missed that one did that one get cut off
at all the [ __ ] confusion here this
almond farmer wrote me said he was
actually listening to the the podcast
while I was talking about almond farm
then he invited me you know to stop by
which is always creepy you know what I
mean those farm houses like I love for
miles is not a hook and she it right but
like they're all scary-looking farm
houses are they're scary during the day
because you never see anybody and he
just always feel like they have all
these this this old [ __ ] they have
like sickles and [ __ ] let's just you
know they can feed you to their pigs I
don't know they're a shady group man
those farmers they're out there by
themselves you can't tell me you don't
slowly go insane when you're [ __ ] a
[ __ ] when you're a farmer you know they
then when you [ __ ] a farmer all right
ladies you keep doing that [ __ ] all
right you don't have to be lonely
playing with his [ __ ] almond scented
balls
all right living off of smoothies oh LSU
by the way LSU is [ __ ] to a now I
watched the whole game I watched the
whole game and I watched so many sports
so much sports this weekend I can t
remember the [ __ ] they played Auburn
Jesus Christ in Auburn right war [ __ ]
eagle right they went down there and
they they went down there and they
[ __ ] I know a lot of those Auburn
people they're upset they lie anyway one
on am [ __ ] passing a fair a Girl Scout
book and calls I am a big proponent of
cornerbacks and how much they get [ __ ]
over but I both of those weren't
interference if you were at the game
that one over the middle look
like [ __ ] because they didn't show
you the full replay where the guy just
held him for like you know ten yards
totally slowed him the [ __ ] down and
then the other one the guy was grabbing
his [ __ ] arm you know it was
borderline sometimes she get away with
it but he got caught but he was doing it
I can tell you this we're [ __ ] 2 1 oh
and what's-his-face their their coach
the hell's his goddamn name I just keep
spacing on his [ __ ] name I'll get it
that's he's he's the best thing in the
SEC if not in the [ __ ] college
football right now I tweeted that he
sounds like a [ __ ] a Cajun Hulk Hogan
adores Iran I'll tell you right now I
think after you run down we without you
what brother he sounds like a [ __ ]
wrestler and he's gotta believe in
themselves and they got a quarterback
that's playing on right now look we all
know the Alabama Crimson Tide is a
[ __ ] professional football team all
right I don't know what the [ __ ] Nick
Saban is doing how he gets all those
good guys how he [ __ ] I don't know what
but that guy is the [ __ ] guy Nick
Saban I love rooting against him but I
love that guy I love Nick Saban you know
I love what he's done with the hella
Bama whatever but you know when I needed
to pick a college team I wasn't gonna
[ __ ] jump on the bandwagon you know I
like rooting against the [ __ ] people
you know what I mean well do you I don't
know maybe you don't anyways
plowing you had living off smoothies hey
Billy fish paste
last week you mentioned you'd love to
just live off smoothies if you could
well it turns out you can
there's an entire niche food market
called meal replacements or complete
foods that contain all the carbs fats
proteins fibers micronutrients and
everything else the body needs to
function properly all in one serving
yeah I know but I get nervous because
when I
I just feel like that it's it's science
and then they always put all these
[ __ ] chemicals and [ __ ] in there some
come in powder form so all you do is mix
it with water others come ready to drink
in the bottle the difference between
them and something shitty like insurer
is that they take human biology and
complete nutritional needs into account
and make sure you get the full
recommended daily intake for all
vitamins minerals and macros and also
most of them are made from whole food
ingredients this is probably what the
future is going to be like when we
[ __ ] destroy the whole planet and the
only people left are living this giant
air conditioned [ __ ] greenhouse and
they just in there with I don't know
what chemicals but they eventually you
need plant they they just have their own
ecosystem and like we're gonna heal the
earth from inside here and then it's
gonna work on the way out there's
another side I always pitched these
sci-fi movies you know a ten years later
they they end up making them like that
[ __ ] population joke that I did that
you take a test they literally made that
[ __ ] movie where's another one for
you you thievin [ __ ] actually go ahead
and make it because I'm not gonna
[ __ ] do it did you just give consent
here's one for you right the whole
[ __ ] world looks like a goddamn
desert is all Waterworld desert and all
that [ __ ] and there's just this one
[ __ ] greenhouse giant [ __ ]
greenhouse the size of Dallas Cowboys
Stadium and in there they actually have
plants they got some chickens and shits
like a [ __ ] Ark that doesn't go
anywhere right and in there is the
perfect [ __ ] ecosystem alright and
then they're gonna gradually like their
thing is is if they have to wait out all
the waste and hope that the planet comes
back and then they gradually every year
they try to expand a little bit more of
this stadium to [ __ ] include more the
more the colibri claim or the [ __ ]
scorched earth right I'm already off the
rails on with this [ __ ] works but
somehow there's a [ __ ] guy in there
he wants to take control and it's
all about the [ __ ] air conditioner
right that was a bad one but something
one of you nerds can figure it out right
alright anyways the one that first came
online a few years ago was called this
is back to the living off smooth
smoothies
Soylent they make powder and pre-mixed
drinks very tasty but there's dozens of
other companies that make similar
products you know one of the guys I fly
with you know his digestive system or
whatever that's all he does and he we
flew back from this place one time when
I was how he was drink this man you'll
be full and I drank it and it felt good
but it was it was too weird I needed I
would need to read up on it
but I know I'm not going to so I'm gonna
stick with what I've been doing but uh
but I would think that you'd be in great
shape right you know it's nice and easy
to digest the funnel depends on what's
in it though right anyway so it doesn't
other companies that make similar
products like Huell he will be happy he
will hu e el Jimmy joy violent and super
body fuel all with their very own
special take on how to fulfill dietary
requirements it's been working for me
for years and I even lived off Soylent
for a month straight a couple years ago
with no issues along with hundreds of
other people but you obviously don't
have to do that you can just use it for
breakfast or ever you want
thanks for all your laughs and go [ __ ]
yourself well let me did you lose a
bunch of weight and [ __ ] like why don't
fat people just [ __ ] do this or look
into it you know because I figured that
once they push through and get off the
sugar salt they can start turning it
around and one of the hardest things to
do about eating healthy is is now you
got to sit there and prepare the [ __ ]
while you're super hungry and your
body's gonna [ __ ] this order a pizza man
order a [ __ ] pizza but if they just
all these containers ready to go you
just shake it up and you drink it that
could actually help some people but I
would definitely if you're gonna do that
if you listen you're thinking of doing
that I would definitely do some research
as far as like what is in them alright
boycott dear Billie boycott how do you
feel about boycotting have you ever
boycotted anything yes I have
have is there any the reason you would
boycott a show podcaster company because
you didn't agree with their behavior
no are not their opinions I would I
would I would like if something sucked
so I guess that's not a boycott then
alright anyways he goes I feel like you
have a thick skin so you probably have
only you probably only have reason to
boycott a group that was censoring you
or your comedy um yeah what I boycott
something what a boycott a company
because of their behavior well I hate
bankers but I still [ __ ] use them so
there goes that yeah I don't know I
don't know I respect people if that's
what they want to [ __ ] do I would put
it that way but like I don't know that I
would like you know I get why people do
that [ __ ] you just have to do a lot to
[ __ ] lose me I think you know what I
mean like I hung in there with Trump and
you know cuz I root for the president
whether I like him or not but like once
his wife wore that yeah I don't really
care do you jacket to that [ __ ] you
know when she was going down to see kids
that were taken away from their parents
I mean whether they're right or wrong
about their way they're handling
immigration or how they want to enforce
it you know that goes out the window
when there's some kid crying missing his
parents and he's he or she's scared you
know you're gonna wear something like
that's that's when they lost me and I
was just laying alright but I still
don't trash them in my act you know God
knows is [ __ ] plenty of people doing
that so I be honest you at this bit this
point in history I think it's really
important rather than to walk away or
something like that it's more important
to try to get something going to talk or
something
because this screaming and yelling [ __ ]
Jesus this come from somebody's will
[ __ ] scream and [ __ ] you know just it
doesn't it doesn't [ __ ] it doesn't
make any sense
I understand why people do what they get
they they get emotional Jesus Christ God
knows I got [ __ ] emotional today this
guy was supposed to move some [ __ ]
furniture on my house it's one of the
[ __ ] workers like I you know I did
all this work on the house and like I
loved the house as much as I [ __ ] about
it and you know I brought it back to
life where a lot of people did some home
depot [ __ ] to it and I try to
restore it you know update it in the
walls but like outside it try to make it
look like you know the time when it was
created was you know so I went I got
these vintage door handles and somebody
swiped one of them and I swear to [ __ ] I
got it back though I got it I raised
[ __ ] holy hell it's one of the few
times my wife didn't give me [ __ ] for
losing my mind I I [ __ ] lost my
[ __ ] mind
what is that about when somebody steals
from you you know it's just that they
it's like I I think who the [ __ ] do you
think I'm that [ __ ] stupid I wasn't
gonna notice do you think I'm the kind
of person that's that's not gonna
[ __ ] pursue this like I will Jesus
Christ
uh-huh well there's a reason I don't
[ __ ] own a firearm you know you can't
you know so that's one of those things
that they should do is they when you go
down and get a [ __ ] gun license they
should like spy on you for a week and
just figure out what irritates you and
then they just come in and do it just
have somebody do it to you in the
parking lot just see how much you lose
your [ __ ] and just see if you shouldn't
have a [ __ ] gun or not I would never
shoot anybody but I think I would
definitely brandish a weapon I'm [ __ ]
wave at somebody's face buddy I am gonna
shoot you in the face you know put your
[ __ ] hands in that dashboard one of
those underrated performances in any
Tarantino movie the guy who played that
[ __ ] cop
in the bathroom scene alright buying a
Lamborghini hey Billy the financial
advisor this might be my favorite
[ __ ] question ever are you gonna buy
a Lamborghini you ever just live
vicariously through somebody I'm more of
a Ferrari guy but God bless you you know
I'm not just like Lamborghini guys are
more flashy hey Billy the financial
advisor I'd appreciate your take my
childhood dream has been to own a
Lamborghini thank god damn it get
yourself one not because of the laws he
says I detract but because I have a huge
interest in cars and they've always been
a motivation for me problem is I'm not a
hundred percent sure if I should I
should he left a word out dropped 250
grand on a car I know the old saying if
you have to ask you can't afford it has
truth to it but I'd like to get advice
from people on a big decision we'll do
it I'm not the guy I'm currently 27 he
says did my masters and work a
commission-based job a realtor and
luckily he had a few good years in the
past from the money I saved I managed to
buy three investment properties I'll
dude yeah yes okay
this is all great stuff I know
technically they belong to the bank but
I've been able to build equity that way
the shitty thing is because I've been
buying these I ended up not buying a
place for myself my parents have been
nice enough to let me stay home with
them I know that this is kind of [ __ ]
up but I'm from South Africa and it's
frowned upon to move out before getting
married well dude you saving a ton of
money so I guess I kind of took
advantage of that night didn't that that
was that rule and you just you're
playing within the rules
anyways also you can tell them what
Patriots fan it's nothing wrong with
that they didn't say can't do it all so
I don't have a girlfriend and actually
don't get laid at all so I'm not doing
it to impress girl I could give a [ __ ]
about him you are just a [ __ ] asexual
money-making machine here sir
my question is should I buy my own place
first then save up for a Lambo or
fulfill my childhood dream now
the reason I don't want to necessarily
buy a place is because then I'll have a
lot of pressure to find a wife and I
know no woman will ever let me spend 250
grand on a car unless I spend 250 grand
on her and because it may delay my dream
another five or so years and I want to
enjoy it while I'm still relatively
young alright wow this guy's really
planning out his life I like this also
if it matters I have about half of the
amount I need saved up so far and will
either save up for another six months to
a year and yes I've researched
maintenance cost and have factored those
into guys done its homework
any help would be appreciated thanks for
the free podcast and any advice from Nia
would be helpful - you guys are great
together and I wish I had friends in
real life like you guys that's really
nice now that I'm done sucking you tick
thanks and go [ __ ] yourself that's
hilarious
alright well I think you know more about
money than I do here's the pros to
buying a Lamborghini
they do retain their value okay if you
don't wrap it around a [ __ ] tree or
modify it or do a bunch you know put a
bunch of miles on it the weird thing
about a Lamborghini is that you know
these [ __ ] guys get them and then
they have them for twenty years and they
sell them and they always have like 800
original miles and it's like why the
[ __ ] did you even have it secondly I
don't know if it helps you that's not a
good look if your real estate agent is
27 and pulls up in a [ __ ] Lamborghini
that would make me feel like this guy's
taking way too much Commission he's
[ __ ] me so I if you're gonna get it I
would not drive it to work and as far as
you're worried about women here's
there's the secret with women is you got
to be upfront with them okay you have to
tell them from [ __ ] day one that this
is what you're doing and then you have
to follow through and do it and don't
let them do that [ __ ] where they go well
that was before I was pretty
nope nope nope all right um I I would
lean I would listen I think there's
there's a massive like bubble being
built in I don't know [ __ ] so people
don't listen to me okay I know I'm a
bald guy and I know I scream but I'm not
that guy on TV who yells about the
stocks I'm just a [ __ ] stupid
comedian okay and I go with my gut and
my gut because I travel around the
country and [ __ ] look at people all
right and what's been freaking me out is
this [ __ ] that I'm talking about where
it's like a [ __ ] Thursday afternoon
I'm on the road and I go to a breakfast
place and it is [ __ ] packed I'm
standing in line like it's Sunday after
church and I'm just looking around going
don't any these [ __ ] people have a
[ __ ] job and I look at them all and
they all have smartphones and they have
[ __ ] iPads and they got [ __ ] their
custom [ __ ] sneakers that they
ordered and everybody is living this
[ __ ] lifestyle and part of this
lifestyles and building all these
[ __ ] luxury high-rise apartments I
mean this is my fifth time around the
block with this [ __ ]
all right started with the [ __ ]
yuppies was the first time I saw it the
[ __ ] dot-com shed the the the housing
bubble everybody's getting a house you
know I'm [ __ ] 10 years ago and now
this [ __ ] so maybe it's my fourth time
through this but this is this is what
happens so I think keep doing what
you're doing with your money and either
stay at home I wouldn't buy that I
wouldn't buy the lawn no I won't I don't
want to talk it's a [ __ ] dream Eeyore
so I I'm there's no way I'm gonna talk a
guy out of his dream or a woman or
hermaphrodite or somebody transitioning
did I cover everybody
am I still in show business I and then
as far as the press you're gonna get to
get married and [ __ ] that
okay at some point you gotta listen I'm
not doing that okay I'm gonna get
married when I find the right person
okay and if you don't know I'm talking
about just watch coming to America okay
I think you're gonna find a lot of
themes that you can relate to
that's your my coming to America is kill
the Irishman
anyways yeah I think you know here's the
thing here's another way to have a
Lamborghini you could have a Lamborghini
for like a year and then turn around and
sell it you know my only thing is is I
think I I would kind of wait until the
[ __ ] Lamborghini is a great thing to
buy during a recession okay unless
you're talking about buying a new one
then you know but um I mean you know
you're always gonna be able to sell a
[ __ ] Lamborghini and I've never seen
well you know what let's [ __ ] look
him up by the way I [ __ ] love the
seam I love anybody with a [ __ ] dream
and this guy like he wants a [ __ ]
Lamborghini and goddammit he's gonna
figure out how to do it I love this
Lamborghini used for sale all right
let's see what we got here let's see
what we got a use Lamborghini first sale
thirty-five thousand nine hundred
dollars $17.99 not see this is why you
don't listen to me is that the poster is
that the actual [ __ ] car are you
serious oh that's a kit you [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's not a real one use Lamborghini way
those are all [ __ ] kit cars you
[ __ ] [ __ ] all right hang on a
second
all right this is more like it
use 2017 Lamborghini Aventador as coupe
I don't I said three hundred ninety nine
thousand seven hundred eleven dollars
used 2007 here's another thing dude you
could [ __ ] get one buy a used one
there's a used 2007 Lamborghini it's
still going to turn heads for ninety
nine thousand nine
$95.00 2017 Lambo you can get for 209
580 two-door coupe and then you can get
a 2018 Volvo s90 for $375 month who the
[ __ ] is looking at this well maybe I'd
like a Volvo use 2008 Lamborghini
murciélago revention coupe for some
reason they want a million 818 what no
[ __ ] way there's another one isn't all
those don't all those are the kiddie
ones these are the big boys here use
2017 Lamborghini Aventador LP 750 for
soup supervillains roadster I know says
650 nine thousand nine nine hundred
dollars these are a year old and these
are all like a half a million bucks yeah
dude you don't wanna spend all this
[ __ ] maybe you do you do I would buy
a used one though I would definitely buy
a [ __ ] used one holy [ __ ] you know
what kills about these things if you go
to the supermarket and drive over a
[ __ ] speed bump please tell me though
sir if you get this thing please take it
to the track please take it to the track
could you please could you please take
it to the track the amount of
Lamborghinis that never go to the
[ __ ] track you know that if I got one
of those [ __ ] things I'd have it on a
flatbed truck I'd take it to the track
and I would meet an instructor there and
be like teach me to drive this thing as
fast as my skill set will allow me
without [ __ ] destroying it all right
let's close on this dilemma but good
luck to you sir you got a lot of great
options okay okay tell the woman what
you're gonna do and stick with it what's
she gonna do beat you up you know and
then secondly you got to let go that
[ __ ] with your parents if you can don't
don't not buy a house because it's some
[ __ ] you know pot of gold at the end
of the rainbow sorry I always have to go
with a [ __ ] some sort of where I'm
from kind of thing here dilemma
everybody dear bill if your life
depended on it would
in Chris Burma's voice what live and
medieval times as a king or make 65
grand a year in the present time oh [ __ ]
that oh my well as a king you'd be able
to [ __ ] any chick you wanted eat well
live well do King [ __ ] but you'd have to
worry about being overthrown or invaded
yeah we're hitting some [ __ ] disease
yeah it's smallpox everyone asked this
question to changes their mind after
talking it out I know I right out of the
gate I was like no brainer I'll take 65
grand a year in the NFL package and I'll
be an absolute [ __ ] nobody
and I'll rub it out to internet porn
before I would go back into medieval
[ __ ] times with scurvy gangrene the
Blackpool scurvy I wouldn't have cuz I'd
be a king I'd have plenty of [ __ ]
vitamin C right I said what it is no
vitamin C no fruit in your diet or some
[ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] all that then everybody come
in to try to [ __ ] kill me and then
just then I the [ __ ] I would have to do
to stay in power putting people in Iron
Maiden's and stretching them out I am
like I don't wanna hurt people you know
then if you're a cool King right I mean
Jesus Christ they be call you [ __ ]
Lord snowflake they with all this
liberal [ __ ] everybody would think
that they could get over on you right
and then you just have to stick someone
in the belly of the beast you know I
think about that [ __ ] all the time I
meant like out of all those things the
Iron Maiden they slam it shut you're
dead you know the rack is [ __ ] brutal
you know the rack they actually they
thought it stretched you in bro kill
your Toria tendons and stuff what it
actually did was a broken bones by
stretching to the point that they
cracked I mean just [ __ ] insane human
beings are so [ __ ] horrible it's it's
it's not even like a keychain you can't
wrap you had around it but the belly of
the beast you know the expression being
in the belly of the beast they would
actually have like some giant looking
bowl thing made out of cast iron or
something and they would put you in
there close it and then light a fire
underneath and basically cook you alive
in the amount of times I thought of what
I would do if I was in there I would
just slam my [ __ ] head
I would [ __ ] I do the Million Dollar
Baby I would bite through my [ __ ]
time but it but to actually [ __ ] you
know hot it have to be before I get
actually the balls to do that is there a
way to just like you know you just rip
your own throat out I would literally I
would try to [ __ ] puncture my neck
and bleed out that's what I would try to
do but they probably put you in their
butt ass naked with your foot all tied
up and [ __ ] I mean just [ __ ] brutal
so it's not even a question dude 65
grand a [ __ ] year in the present you
know my dress like Albert Einstein same
[ __ ] clothes every day except it be
more than Malcolm young wardrobe rest
his soul you know I've been you know
going through a lot of [ __ ] here and I
actually found this Malcolm young like
action should get thing that I have not
actually figure it's like it's but I
bought the thing I never assembled it
because you had to came from somewhere
in Asia so you know Angus didn't get any
money on it and you [ __ ] you got a
glue his feet to the [ __ ] base and
I've been meaning to go over to one of
these [ __ ] mom-and-pop department
stores you know [ __ ] Home Depot I mean
anytime like you want to talk about
someone who gets act like a king over
this you can actually find somebody on
the floor that can that doesn't have 20
people like running after them you know
like when the dog whisperer goes over
the hill he's have $20 about 20 kids
behind him our dogs behind them that's
us what the [ __ ] at Home Depot's like so
anyways yeah I would take 65 grand a
year great question though great
questions great I hope that guy it's
gonna work out for you buddy all right
if you want you got to tell something
the first dates tell you about yourself
I've always wanted a Lamborghini you
know Jesus what kind of woman would that
attract I don't know but that's your
dilemma buddy good luck with it all
right go [ __ ] yourselves I'll check in
on ya on Thursday